- [Voiceover] "To help
freshmen and sophomores
"in selecting their courses,
"candid reviews of courses and instructors
"compiled by juniors and seniors."
So this already feels very strange.
They're giving us a subject,
which is "candid reviews
of courses and instructors
"compiled by juniors and seniors."
So what they've underlined here
which we're gonna think about
if there's a better way of phrasing it,
that already feels like the
subject of our sentence.
And because they're saying, "To
help freshmen and sophomores
"in selecting their courses,"
essentially giving us
this prepositional phrase,
it's implying that the candid reviews
of courses and instructors
compiled by juniors and
seniors did something
to help freshmen and sophomores
in selecting their courses.
They're not telling us
what the candid reviews,
they're not telling us
what the stuff in orange
right over here,
what did they do?
Another way to think about it,
they gave us the subject.
That's why over here in orange,
"Candid reviews of courses and instructors
"compiled by juniors and seniors."
Well they're not telling us what they did
to help freshmen and sophomores
in selecting their courses.
We don't know what the action
here is of the sentence.
We don't know what the
predicate of the sentence
actually is.
So I don't like it as it is,
it's not really making any sense.
So we can rule out the first choice
which is always the sentence as is.
Now let's look at the other choices.
"Candid reviews of courses and instructors
"being compiled by juniors and seniors."
So once again,
that just keeps this as a
whole subject right over here.
It still doesn't tell
us what this thing did
to help freshmen and sophomores
in selecting their courses.
There's no predicate.
So I'll rule that out.
"And to compile candid reviews
"of courses and instructors
by juniors and seniors."
So this one really sounds disjoint.
"To help freshmen and sophomores
"in selecting their courses,
"and to compile candid reviews
"of courses and instructors
by juniors and seniors."
So it's really this compound
prepositional phrase,
and they're really not even giving us
a subject or a predicate right over here.
Who's doing what to do this
and to do this?
So this one is also I
would say fairly bizarre.
"Juniors and seniors have
compiled candid reviews
"of courses and instructors."
So I like this one
because this is actually
a complete sentence.
This actually a complete sentence
even if you did not have
the prepositional phrase
in the beginning.
What's your subject here?
Well your subject is juniors and seniors.
What did they do?
Well they have compiled candid reviews
of courses and instructors.
So this by itself is a complete sentence
and we could throw this
prepositional phrase on the front
to say, "Well why did they do this?
"To help freshmen and sophomores
in selecting their courses."
So we get, "To help
freshmen and sophomores
"in selecting their courses,
"juniors and seniors,"
that's the subject,
"have compiled candid reviews
of courses and instructors."
That one feels very good.
Now let's just look at this last one.
"With juniors and seniors
compiling candid reviews
"of courses and instructors."
So once again it's just another phrase,
not really giving us once again
a complete expression here.
They're not giving us a
complete subject with an action.
So I would rule this one out as well.